I happen to believe a lot of people like they would try to go they try to have like a big bang for their 100th
Episode you know they try to do something big actually
But I feel like no the 100 should be your low point like you should if you can make 100 worse than episode 1
So that way nobody says man. They really picked it episode 100 right like you can say boy
I feel like an episode 100 like they got their second win
So I think we just got to make a horrible show today, and we're fine
I think it's good that you're setting everyone's expectations for the yeah, thank you. Yeah, I like that
That's right go for like I'm gonna go for a more intimate feeling right we're gonna be more
Together and it's not gonna be just a big bang. It's gonna be just condensed and we're gonna all express our opinions
And then you just take it to like this is gonna be terrible. Yeah
Yeah, well expectations. There's no disappointment you guys yeah, yeah, you guys ever see that mad TV bit about lowered expectations
That's beautiful man, that was really nice. This is Linux unplugged episode 100 for July 7th 2015
Welcome to Linux unplugged your weekly Linux talk show that's honestly struggling with a bit of food coma from a little bit too much barbecue
My name is Chris and joining me in studio well one of the several gentlemen joining me in studio is Wes hey Wes
Hey gang hey there welcome, and thanks for joining me in studio and eating my barbecue my pleasure
Last week I put the call out. I said you know for episode 100
I wanted to do a meetup, but we have so much going on
We've just done a bunch of meetups
And we have a couple of coming up kind of didn't really fit in the schedule
So why not just have people over to the studio and do a little cookout we had six people RSVP
And we had a pool going I said three would show up. I nailed it three people showed up
Were you the first to make it I think so yeah, yeah, it was nice
That was good, and so we had I had the barbecue going
I figured because we're up north a little bit people used to show up a little late
So I didn't even start the barbecue until like about the time
I thought people were maybe supposed to start showing up so that way there was plenty of time
And then as people trickled in we had the barbecue ready to go we've been talking Linux. It's been nice
Oh, yeah, play a little Ronald jankies while we ate and so I thought today to celebrate episode 100
We would do the only thing pop pop proper the only thing you're supposed to do for your 100th episode is not playing anything clip show
Yeah, ha ha ha clip show that would actually be even better. It's just sit back here play all the clips
They don't do anything. We just play everything no actually that would have been way more way more clever actually
I should have thought of that no no today. We'll do yeah
Yeah, I will do it for 200 exactly now today. We'll do a little a brief retrospect
We'll do a little navel gazing, but we won't go too far
We'll just talk I just we kind of look back over the hundred weeks this shows been on the air
And I don't think we've missed a single week. I don't think I don't think so and some really interesting stuff has developed
And then we're gonna have a review of the new Linux mint release of based on that cinnamon the 17.2
And then towards the end of the show a brand new tiny tiny device is running Linux that is x86 based
And you're gonna be able to get your hands on it for pretty cheap really soon so before we dig into all of that
Let's bring in that virtual lug time appropriate greetings mumble room
Thank you guys hello huge turnout today look at that. It's scrolling off the screen there
We got so many people in the in the mumble room. Hey there guys
I like Popey must like start before I'm done. That's the only way I can figure is he's always in there first he nails it
So we're gonna talk about a little bit of the show's history
And so that's one of the reasons why Wes here is joining us in the first segment is out of the group here
Wes has been probably watching since closest from the beginning what you said about a couple years. Yeah, you know I think
About episode 18 okay, not bad all right well, so guess what this is all gonna be in your wheelhouse then so I didn't want
To go like way way way way far back
But let's start with more recent history some episodes that were just kind of my favorites of Linux unplug
These are like if you're if you're new to the show
We'll just point out a couple things that I thought were interesting and you guys you can chip in if you want or not
But starting kind of more recently episode 70 when we looked at well first of all we talked with the fedora project about
Them them switching to this ring cycle where they have fedora core again
Fedora workstation fedora server and all of that was around the fedora 21 release and the restructuring of their project
And I really we did a couple of a couple of week coverage of that and we had them come on and discuss it with us
And do a roundtable discussion
I thought that was a really interesting way to sort of approach like a big well-known distro going through a major restructuring
It's really help people wrap their heads around it and so that was in episode 7. I'm thinking in the future
If there was a distro that had a big change like that
There'll be it's nice to kind of just really double down on it
I think that's one of the best things about unplugged is you can connect
Developers with the people who are actually using them. Yeah, they come into the room
Yeah, I like that right there and sometimes like, you know behind the scenes rotten corpse gonna test of this. Are you still in there rotten?
Yep, we've had to have rotten write up a tutorial and like he you know
He has to work with the guests a lot of times to get them set up with mumble
Oh because we have them come in and hang out with the rest of the lug and you know
A lot of times like the last time Matt from fedora was on the project. He
He actually had to get and build and package mumble for fedora 22 because it wasn't a mumble available for door 22 yet
So sometimes our guests will go really about
Just peer pressure our guests they'll go above and beyond to you know
Cuz they have to go install this extra piece of software configure it to our mumble server
And but then they get to hang out and and the people in the room can ask questions, too
So that's that's pretty neat. So while we're still navel-gazing and we're looking back keep going back to episode 68
That's when we talked to Charlie and his students from Penn Manor School District where we got to talk about how they gave each student
Root access to their rigs. I was episode 68 Linux powered schools
I love the concept of trusting the students with root access and the way Charlie empowered students to be the
IT people and all of that was really neat and now they're still getting some recognition
They just got written up in a Red Hat magazine just recently
Oh, and I was just up there robe from warhead episode 57 going right through these because I hate talking about ourselves
System D haters busted. There was a whole swath of system D. This is the part I've been rushing towards man
Did we have some serious system D episodes another one another sentinel sentinel Seminole Seminole. Thank you. Thank you
Another really important that system D episode was
Episode 27 Debbie and system D decision where it was announced. Can you believe it was that long ago? It seems ages ago
February 11th
One of the bumpier chapters in Debbie and history. It looks to be drawing to a close at least for now
What was all the drama about it was the switch to system D?
Now it seems so far ago, you know, no problems
I'm so glad to be in an abundant who have switched to system D now, you know, just how it's all gone quiet
Yeah, it really has in a big way, hasn't it? What do you think that means is it?
I think it means all the haters were making a fuss about nothing because they didn't know what they were talking about which I think
Strictly summarizes what we were saying at the time. Yeah, they actually tried it finally
Or they don't realize they're using it now because it just works. Yeah
I think that's a little unfair. I think that's characterizing everyone who was anti system D as a hater
Is a little bit unfair because some of them were some of them were yes. Okay. It's a general. Yeah. Yeah, yeah, I agree
I'm referring to the peanut gallery. I think a better summary that the haters have moved on
You know the rest of us have made you or enjoyed it. Yeah, I guess maybe that's it to the haters
Or did they're just not using systems that use system D right there are options out there free BSD converse
So as we're as we're talking about system D who's installed Dev1 recently?
Dev1 I haven't heard anything about that. No, I haven't either and the room goes silent. Yeah, I forgot that existed
Yeah, I haven't but I wonder what I wonder what they did with all your money. Oh
That's right. They were taking donations about that. How about that?
So yeah, boy, the system D stuff was really fascinating. So from I mean, it's such a range that it covered and I know there's a
Certain amount of time where it really got burned out
But now it's we have a little bit of interesting history in there. So I wow
Well, that is really something I so West have you had a chance to use it much? Yeah
I mean, I run an arch at home. So system B is pretty much on all of my systems
Yeah, I use a lot of legacy init scripts at work and having a sane set status command
Regardless of if the author of the system to the init script bothered to write one is a godsend. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm
Yeah, once you have used in a production environment if in a server environment, it's it's very nice
I want it. There's a lot of places a lot of moments that unplugs history where we talked about
Docker
And Docker, you know following Docker was it's been really fascinating episode 16 meet the dockers
A new version of Docker was released
So we brought on the CTO and founder of Docker to chat about the new version of Docker
And that was really like an interesting moment in Docker history before well before the one oh well before the partnership with Red Hat and VMware
And all the other companies that they now work with but well before Coral West and and rocket and all of that
We talked with the CTO and founder of Docker in episode 16. I thought that was pretty interesting then. Oh, and Ron. Did you have any?
I'm just saying it's it kind of sounds like where the Linux unplugged is like container hipsters
We were hip to we were hip to Docker before everybody else was
Kota radio has this beat by a few weeks actually so Kota Rick Mike Mike found Docker before Docker was even like
He found it really early on when they were just desperate to get people to know about it
And then one of the most popular and of course the older the show is the more downloads it gets so this isn't a super fair metric
But episode 15 of Linux unplugged don't switch to Linux has been one of the most popular episodes on YouTube and one of the like
People have people have written me at saying that I have done more damage to Linux with this episode title then in anything any other
Don't switch to Linux. They I have been told is single-handedly hurting a Linux adoption because of that title
But it at least you got a legacy. I guess that's after all this work. That'll be my legacy
You know if I recall it was like what episode 15 was about was Linux is amazing
But we're gonna get to that in the next episode
15 was about was Linux is amazing, but we're gonna we're just gonna tell you here's a couple of the elephants in the room when you switch
Gotta be real. Yeah, and like I was just telling you guys during lunch
Our former nanny who is no longer our nanny
Her Macbook died and so Noah got her Dell laptop, and she liked it. She likes it
Oh, I was already using the office. She says it was great. Oh, I was already using Firefox
It's great, and I'm thinking to myself. This is gonna be perfect. So it's I think you put up onto LTS on there and
And
She had it for about two days, and then she calls me up, and she says so um Chris. Yeah, what's up?
I'm having a hard time with something. What is it? I can't is it is is there no iTunes for Linux? Oh?
No, there's no iTunes Jenny. I didn't even I didn't even think to tell her of course not I mean
I don't use iTunes I who uses iTunes a lot of people use iTunes
But Linux users don't use iTunes
But those are the kinds of things that we covered in the don't switch to Linux is like there's some there's a lot of
Good stuff, but there's some gotchas, too
And and so that I was surprised by the reaction because I felt like if you listen to the episode
It was kind of obvious what we were trying to go for
But boy did we get a lot of hate for that
And so episode 15 that was like ever since it was like oh
I don't want to I don't want to be flame baby in the titles anymore. I'm sorry. I'm sorry
But we've matured since then the real yeah the real funny thing about Linux unplugged is it started as a show?
Simply to handle the overflow of mail. We were getting from the Linux action show. I was getting so much email
Then this is well before I'd like before we had the contact forms really where it were
Really good
And we have the subreddit as a as a really good form for feedback so everything was coming in my inbox my inbox
And I realized I was spending as much time reading email every week as I would just to prep a show
So then I thought well well here's an idea
Why don't I just turn all this email reading into show prep, and I'll just sit down. I'll read and respond to emails
Nobody'll want to listen to show like that, but if I'm gonna do it anyways. I'll just do it and so that was like episode 1
You know it was like yeah, maybe I'll try like here's in a concept episode 2 and 3 you know
Go doc yourself. What was that about? Oh? Yeah? Oh? Yeah? That was a little KD hate
You know I played with it a little I and then I realized pretty early on that nobody
Nobody wants to listen to a show where some guys read an email
Nobody is yeah. Yeah, she's a witch
Which show did you?
Introduce the mumble chat room then I think it was this show I?
Think so no no as in which episode oh
Good thing to find. Oh, I that is a really really good question. Do you think it wasn't an episode 1?
It was episode 1. I'm thinking that maybe a chat with our live hangout. Maybe we did a hangout for the first episode
But yeah, we had a panel discussion about we should our first episode
We talked about the lava bit shut down, and if it was time to start rolling our own email servers
That was our panel discussion on the first episode. It looks like so it started out dicey
Yeah, yeah, the lava bit stuff was kind of a was kind of a mess wasn't it I remember that Levar Levinson and the whole
He was hosting Snowden's emails right yeah, that's that's right. That was what lava bit was about
Now he's off doing the dark mail initiative, and I think we interviewed him one of our shows even might have been unplugged
That's a great question though. Hmm. Yeah, I do read. It's funny. I greater says now
I no longer read emails in love. I don't read as many I do read a few, but
Yeah, I don't read as many now because we read more emails in the Linux action show these days
So it kind of it kind of
Softened up on that well in the mumble room brings all the complaints that you could pass that's true
Yeah, you got we got live feedback right there, right, and you got a chat room. You got a chat room, too
Hey, you know what?
It's something that just crossed my mind. I got I got to get your info before you go
I gotta get everybody who visited today. We're gonna give away a special for the you guys have visited a special
Linux unplugged 100 t-shirt. Oh boy. I just remind everyone I was here first yeah, so there you go
So and we're gonna make it available
Just for like a day or two or probably like a couple of days if you would like to pick it up out there in
The audience teespring.com slash lup 100
It's just a sure we threw together celebrate episode 100. We're not gonna make a big run of it. We're not gonna make a big deal
I don't even think we'll probably update the website
So it's just for you guys if you're a fan of the show and we're selling it basically at cost $19
Because once you add shipping and stuff, it's gonna be a little bit more than that and there's also a long sleeve version
which are pretty great and it's at teespring.com slash lup lup 100 if you would like it and
for you guys who visited just
Give me your deets and I'll for them on to and she'll order some for you guys because you made the trip and I'll put a link to that in the chat room too again that's teespring.com slash lup 100 if you want to grab it and I don't know how long we'll run it because I really just kind of want to be something special just for those of you who listen to episode 100 of the unplug program.
That was something I wanted to do too and we only need three more prints to make the run because we're just doing a couple so and it'll be running I guess it's running for 14 days I guess we'll probably just run the couple of days.
I guess it's running for 14 days I guess we'll probably just run the clock out on it that probably makes the most sense teespring.com slash lup 100 all right so that'll bring us to the end of the navel gazing I appreciate you guys letting me do that I thought it was fun to kind of look back over 100 weeks and see some of the more interesting things that have developed and you know it's funny because on the pre show we're like no we don't want to talk about this again all we don't want to talk about this and we were talking like Firefox and system D and the reality is we feel like we talk ourselves out too much like it's oh my gosh we've we've beat it to death.
But when you go back with a little perspective and look at it it's and I'm just saying this based on you know 300 plus episodes of last two it is.
It's a it's an uncanny time capsule it is like getting in a time machine and going back to that moment and you realize there was so like we look back at this stuff now and we see in very broad terms the Debbie and distribution switched over to system D and there was some debates and there was in fighting.
But back then the nuance is so rich and so detailed that when you actually go back and listen to the back and I go wow I can't believe we're worried about this or an old man that was such a big deal and like it's very fascinating.
So it's all respect what's that it's a good retrospect.
Yeah yeah for 200 we should actually clip it all together.
That's a good idea. I like that. Thank you. Thank you. That's good thinking. All right. Well so well we're going to shift gears and talk about Linux Mint 17.2 and the flavor of cinnamon that you can get with that addition.
But first I want to tell you about our first sponsor and that is DigitalOcean. In fact go over to DigitalOcean.com right now and remember our promo code of absolute power and wisdom that is D O unplugged one word lowercase D O unplugged.
They'll give you a ten dollar credit over DigitalOcean and you can try out their five dollar rig two months for free. Now DigitalOcean is a simple cloud hosting provider dedicated to offering the most intuitive and easy way to spin up your own cloud server.
Now a cloud server is really a rig up on the DigitalOcean data center that is powered by Linux running on top of Linux in the KVM virtualizer and you can choose from core OS free BSD Fedora Ubuntu Debbie and lots of distributions to pick from one click application deployments and you can get started in less than 55 seconds.
I can't even believe this is somebody who used to create virtual machines for a living using like clunky VMware ESXi platform tools and things where I had to run a Windows box to create a Linux machine those days to be able to create a machine in 55 seconds blows my freaking mind.
And at five dollars a month you're going to get 512 megabytes of RAM a 20 gigabyte SSD one CPU and a terabyte of transfer a terabyte.
Jeez wow and here's another great thing DigitalOcean data center locations in New York, San Francisco, Singapore, Amsterdam and London they got a brand new hotness in Germany with 40 gigabit E connections to each hypervisor their fastest SSDs yet and that thing is located in great great great locations all of its neighbors have fantastic speed but look at DigitalOcean's interface.
In fact it's worth using our promo code just to play with that go over to DigitalOcean.com use the promo code DOUNPLUG get that $10 credit also help support this show and then try out their interface.
You know it's super intuitive it supports web standards which is really nice which means it's going to work on your tablet or your desktop that is great if you're on the go.
They also have a fantastic API that allows you to replicate the functionality really really well done and there's so many great community apps built around that API.
For like me I just take advantage of those apps and for those of you out there that use unity for your desktop there are applets that snap right into the Ubuntu desktop to manage your droplet.
I don't actually know how well they work on other desktops but I did notice they're also available in the AUR so I know I'm users and whatnot I think you could actually install them as well.
There's also tons of command line applications Android iOS management tools things to snap it into puppet whatever you need to do there's probably somebody's already written some code for it or you can take advantage of that API just remember that promo code.
That's what supports the show and keeps us going for another hundred episodes DOUNPLUG you apply that you get a $10 credit no credit card required DOUNPLUG try out their $5 rig two months for free.
If you're in our chat room right now the functionality of the J-Bot powered by a digital ocean droplet my chat room powered by a digital ocean droplet using Quasal core my own cloud my bit torrent sync my Minecraft servers the back end systems that we use for transferring files between on location and production in the studio.
All of it powered by digital ocean our Jitsi server that we bounce off of a digital ocean droplet I'm telling you it can be your back end infrastructure for testing or for production digitalocean.com use the promo code DOUNPLUG and a big big thank you to digital ocean for sponsoring the Linux unplugged program.
You guys are fantastic.
All right well now sitting down to join me at the mic is Romeo.
Hey Romeo welcome to Linux unplugged man.
Hey Chris.
So thank you first of all for making the trip out from Portland right.
Yeah yeah.
Good man.
And also not only that you also volunteered to be our Linux Mint 17.2 Cinnamon user.
And so I saw you have it installed here on a Lenovo laptop.
Is it a Lenovo?
Oh it is a Lenovo.
See I thought it was a Lenovo.
And what do you think of it.
What do you want to start is it how is the installation experience out of box Wi-Fi hardware.
How's all that work for you.
Well I mean installation is pretty standard nowadays.
I mean we nailed that a while ago.
It's nothing to write home about.
It's a Linux installation from USB.
It's what it is.
Wi-Fi worked out of the box which it didn't in 17.1 when I use this laptop.
It's a Broadcom in that?
Yeah Broadcom chip.
Which was exciting.
I was pretty hyped about that and it carried over my Wi-Fi settings from the install.
I love that.
I thought that was really cool.
Yeah and more and more distros are doing that.
And man does it stand out now when a distribution doesn't do that.
Yeah definitely.
I didn't notice a whole lot of changes when I was just using it regularly.
Theming is really easy.
Do they still support like the automatic downloading of themes online inside the like theme control panel?
No.
At least not that I could find.
It seems that they've removed that functionality.
I don't really know why you have to download them manually and pop them into your dot themes.
Which isn't difficult but my grandma wouldn't do it.
Right, having it built in there is very nice sort of KDE-esque too.
Yeah, yeah.
I looked at the changelog and they say they fix the screensaver not actually being a screensaver.
Nice.
They put some new repos on but it's only 14.04.
I mean.
Yeah that's right, right.
Did you feel that when you're using it?
Does it feel old?
It feels sluggish even though they say that they've improved and sped up and optimized Cinnamon a lot.
I didn't feel it.
For me it felt slower than when I used 17.1.
Maybe it's drivers being weird.
Maybe it's something else but I didn't feel the speed improvements they were talking about.
And admittedly this is on a very low-end laptop.
It's a ThinkPad X131E which isn't the best but I mean it should be able to run Cinnamon.
Yeah and it's ran it before.
Yeah it has.
And it has an Intel graphics so you've played Race the Sun on it so it can do 3D acceleration.
I believe it's actually AMD.
Oh okay.
But it's enough to actually have 3D compositing.
Yeah.
So the Cinnamon should have everything it needs to be snappy.
It is but.
And the Cinnamon menu still hasn't opened when I hit the.
Is that, hit it again.
Did it even register?
Yeah.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah that is a bit laggy.
Yeah.
So I thought that was worth mentioning.
It's like my play and pause and brightness and those all worked out of the box which they didn't last time.
So it seems kind of like they're just making it more stable.
Making it more of a distro that'll just work on everything.
I noticed they're refining a few things that seemed kind of appealing.
Like I don't know if you had a chance to play with this but I guess they have like a new inhibit feature for notifications now.
I didn't play with that but I did see that they did that and I thought that it was cool.
Yeah that's nice.
I don't want any notifications for a while.
Just turn this crap off. That's a great idea.
And not just that but it also disables your screen saver.
And screen blanking in total which on my desktop I just wrote a script for that.
Yeah.
Caffeine is another desktop application you can get that'll do that.
Yeah yeah.
And it's nice like when you're watching a movie or a live show or something like that.
And when I looked at like you were saying what I saw was like so one of the things they've listed is improved system settings.
Like a better layout of the system settings and when you go through there now does it feel like it's one nice cohesive place to configure the system?
I went into the system settings and I didn't notice anything which I think is what they were going for.
Yeah it's probably a good sign.
Because it felt a little hodgepodge in the past and looking at these screenshots it seems pretty good.
Now Wimpy I think on the pre-show you were mentioning you might have had some questions regarding the Cinnamon release of Mint or I'm sorry of Mint.
Well you've just covered some of it there.
I mean I find listening to podcasts that do distro reviews really useful because I have too long commutes a day and I can listen to other people reviewing distributions and I can get hints and ideas about how to improve the one I make.
So all of this I find fascinating.
I am intrigued by your experience with it being based on 14.04.
So I'm assuming user land applications all feel very current and modern right? It's the latest Firefox.
Yeah I mean all that stuff is fine.
Yeah it's all taken care of.
It's usable but I don't know why they went with 14.04.
Do you do me a favor? What's the version of the kernel that's used in there? Do you give it a new name or something for me?
I'm just kind of curious to see. They probably have it listed on the specs page.
Now here's the nice thing about this. So it sounds like your biggest takeaway is the performance is not quite as good as you're hoping especially since they kind of made that a cornerstone aspect of the release.
But the flip side is this is a long term supported edition.
So this is something you could give friends or family and they would have years of patches coming from this thing.
So that's something to consider. Wimpy you wanted to jump in.
Well you were saying about why is it based on 14.04 and this was something I discussed with Clem way back when this was first put out as an idea.
Well it really comes down to the fact that with each new version of Ubuntu the Mint team being outside of the Ubuntu family if you like.
They had to keep re-engineering things and fixing things and moving with this shifting base system.
And one of the other criticisms was that you couldn't upgrade between Mint releases or you could sometimes and sometimes it didn't work so well.
So the decision was to base on an LTS and then iterate on top of a stable largely unchanging base system.
So they could actually concentrate on developing their own tools and applications without having the constant churn beneath them with the operating system changing.
So that was the rationale and part of that was fueled by when is system D going to land.
What's happening with Wayland and Mir and what that might mean for distribution such as Mint and elementary and how they would have to adapt.
It buys them a couple of years to let that kind of thing shake out.
Yeah just let those things shake out yeah.
Now also I've been reading online that a lot of people are upgrading from 17.1 to 17.2 which is not something normally done in a Mint release.
But I guess because they're both based on 14.04 there's actually a way to do this now.
Yeah because you're not doing a distribution release upgrade you're effectively upgrading packages on top of a base OS.
Which is nice for Mint users because that's always been a mismatch.
Mint is great for people that aren't very comfortable but every time you want to go to the next version you have to completely reload.
They're actually going to do that another time for the next release which is 17.3 and the next one who knows because that's going to be 18 and it's going to be LTS to LTS.
So maybe they'll have an upgrade maybe not.
Now did you see the kernel version there?
Yes I've got 3.16.
3.16 is not bad okay.
Alright so it's not 3.13 that's all I care about.
It's also actually got a kernel versioning manager thing so you can actually update and choose which kernel you want.
Or avoid it all together I think too.
Yeah as well.
Interesting.
There's actually a lot of things that they're doing that are LTS based but they are actually updating packages and updating different security software and stuff outside of just the LTS point releases.
They're doing more than just that.
There's a few applications that I've experienced where they've actually updated in the past couple months or so that were like a year old in the Ubuntu versions.
So they're not doing it for everything but they are doing it a lot more than any other distro based on LTS.
Do you remember which applications those were?
No I don't.
I remember some of the applications that are not in the repo at all that they added like some proprietary stuff like they added Sublime and stuff like that.
I like that.
Sublime is great.
You know last week what I was trying to sort of hazardly say and I'll just very plain stately say this time is I'm still a little confused why I wouldn't go with Ubuntu Mate or Ubuntu LTS itself over Mint.
If I'm really going out on a ledge and say I'm going to pull a NOA and I'm going to ship somebody a laptop halfway across the country and I'm never even probably going to see them.
I don't know if I would do anything but an official Ubuntu flavor for that person because it just feels like you're deviating the further you deviate from that official status like the more room there is for something you don't know about or something you don't have oversight over or something just weird to break.
I don't know maybe it doesn't seem like a main issue because I've moved people to Mint and had success with it and I've never had a problem but I'm just trying to think like where if I'm trying to pick between the two what the core advantage over say Mint Cinnamon edition is say over Ubuntu Mate or Ubuntu 14.04 LTS.
What do you think?
I feel like Mint Cinnamon tries to be intentionally a lot like Windows.
The start menu is very similar to Windows. The two finger scrolling isn't a thing. They use the Windows Edge scrolling.
Just the general usage of it feels a little bit like Windows but almost like not in a bad way though.
Sometimes I'll say that to put something down like oh it feels like I'm using Windows 7 and maybe somebody might describe an old version of KDE like that.
But with Cinnamon it's got a start menu but it's now a better start menu than what Windows has.
It's like they've refined it in a way where they took some concepts that if you're familiar with Windows you'll see there in Cinnamon and they'll be somewhat reminiscent but they're not like a one-to-one copy of the concept.
It's easy for the Windows people to get into which is what everyone's been saying about Mint since as long as I can remember.
That really is a main advantage to it isn't it? And one of the big advantages to it is if you're switching a Windows user it's going to be kind of comfortable for Cinnamon.
How's the stability been? Any crashing or anything like that?
I haven't had any crashing other than the general sluggishness.
Corky wants to throw his hat in the ring. Go ahead Corky.
I'd have to say Cinnamon is definitely the most important thing about Linux Mint. I've four switches I've used Cinnamon for because I find it great for switching people and Linux Mint is the only way you can go if you want proper Cinnamon implementation.
And you like GTK apps too which is nice. If you still like the GTK apps but you want something a little more traditional and Gnome 3 isn't your thing or it's going to be way too different if you're switching and you don't want to go to KDE.
Yeah I like that.
Okay so 17.2 and if you have any experiences with it out there and want to share it with us at linuxactionshow.reddit.com find the feedback thread for episode 100 and let us know.
I'd specifically like to hear your experiences with the performance aspect. How has that been? Anybody in the Mamba Room want to chime in? Anybody tried 17.2 that has opinions before we, Hip Scott, jump around? Nope, go in once.
I looked at 17.2 for accessibility but that's just me though.
Okay I'd love to hear about that.
So in 2.6 they started work on accessibility for Cinnamon so that's what 17.2 has, Cinnamon version 2.6 and above. But it's still not there yet. It works in terms of just kind of navigating, getting around.
Nemo is not sort of accessible but there are some things that don't work as well. Some of the keyboard functionality when you want to assign keyboards like keyboard shortcuts and things, those don't work with Orca.
The panel is sort of accessible but there needs to be some work done. But the start is there so hopefully the ball will keep rolling.
How is it compared to say Unity or Gnome or KDE?
So KDE is not accessible as of right now. Apparently there's some move for that to happen. Unity is sort of accessible but the functionality is not really there for Orca users.
But in terms of Gnome or Mate, Gnome and Mate are the most accessible out of the box for Orca users.
Cool. That is really good to hear that perspective because that's obviously something that's very hard for us to test so I really do appreciate you mentioning that.
And also a grader in the chat room points out that if you're not a SystemD fan, Mint 17.2 is a bastion of non-SystemD-ness for you which also probably explains why it's taking a little while to boot up.
It might have to do with the hard drive encryption.
Oh you have it encrypted?
Yeah I've got the hard drive encrypted and the Gnome folder encrypted.
That definitely could take a bit of a hit. Yeah for sure.
For boot up time but I don't think that would affect after I've booted up.
It might but yeah I don't know. It might still. Just even though it has the key it still might. I don't know. That's a good question. I'd be curious to see what it would be like with or without it off.
So how was that setting that up? Pretty easy?
Yeah during the install process it was just check a box.
Enter your master password?
Yeah. Cool. And were you able to set one master password for all of them? Or was it different passwords for your home and a different password for your root?
I set a different password for my home and a different password for the root.
Cool. That's really neat. Well very nice. Well thank you for doing that and thank you for coming in from Portland to give us that review in studio too. That was really awesome.
And jump back in and let us know how it goes. Are you going to keep it installed or are you switching to something else?
I'm going back to Arch.
Okay. Alright well thank you for trying it for a little bit. Yeah I know how you feel too.
Alright well then I'll take a moment and I'll thank our next sponsor right here on the Linux Unplugged program. Of course that's our friends over at Ting.
Go to linux.ting.com to get our special $25 discount off your first Ting device or $25 in service credit if you have a Ting compatible device and you just might because Ting has a GSM network and a CDMA network.
Now here's what I love about Ting. You only pay in for what you use. This is phenomenal.
If you've got like a device, like a little tiny computer device that maybe is doing some monitoring or some sort of sensors, you could put a GSM SIM card in that thing and give it internet access for $6 a month.
Why? Tings only pay for what you use with a flat $6 for the line. They just take your messages, your minutes, your megabytes, they add that all up and that's what you pay in.
That's really simple. And they have a dashboard to help you keep it all straight and it's really a good system.
And because I'm pretty savvy like with the Wi-Fi or I'll use anything. I'll use Hangouts, I'll use Skype, I'll use SIP now with NOAA.
Man, I don't even – we're like seven days into the month. I've probably got like a handful of minutes used total. It's so slick.
And so if you're savvy like that, it's really useful. And here's the best part. You can get a whole team of people on there, right? And $6 a line, that's not going to cost you anything.
And it's just your usage. And then when they get stuck, you can just have them call the Ting customer service. It's no-hold customer service.
You just call and get to speak to a human at 1-855-TING-FTW. That's really nice if you don't want to get stuck having to help people because they've got really good service.
They've also got great online support and a fantastic dashboard. And one of the great things about Ting is to save my butt a few times is you can just turn on hotspot and tethering.
So if you need data, like oh, maybe I don't know, Comcast goes out on you, happens, and you just turn on the hotspot and tethering and you get Ting's tri-band LTE.
I'm getting like 20 megabits in the studio. It's really nice. Plus they've got a whole range of devices from basic devices like feature phones all the way up to the Nexus 6, the best stuff.
And one of the things I really like about Ting is they always are iterating on the features around the Ting platform. And so they have a Ting app.
I've told you a little bit about it before. You can find more about it at ting.com slash app. And of course Kyra is here. She's got a little discussion for us too.
I mean I could sit here and tell you about it, but what I love about the Ting app is everything good you need to manage your Ting account.
And why have me tell you about it when Kyra could tell you all about it? Go Kyra. Take it Kyra.
This is the Ting app of the week. It's also meta. I'm Kyra and this is the Ting app of the week.
I love you.
At Ting we pride ourselves on giving you the tools to take control of your cell phone bill.
Practically anything you do in your Ting account dashboard on a computer can be done inside the Ting mobile app.
The usage panel shows how many minutes, messages and megabytes your account and all your devices have used.
Tap a number to check out recent activity on that device. Tap again for detailed event info.
Easily enable or disable device settings like international calling, internet access and picture messaging.
You can view your current bill and detailed billing history and set alerts and caps to keep things under control.
You can also give us a call, access our help site or submit a help request right through the app.
You can also stay up to date on the latest Ting news by hitting the blog.
You could even watch this episode of the app of the week featuring the Ting app on the blog within the Ting app.
Just be careful not to create a glitch in the matrix.
The Ting app is available on Android and iOS devices and is free.
You'll find links to the Ting app below or just search Ting in the Google Play or the App Store.
Thanks for watching!
Hey Kyra, and Kyra's all in. Kyra over at Ting was all in and you can get all into linux.ting.com.
Support the show and only pay for what you use. That's right, go to linux.ting.com.
Alright, so now we are sort of winding down towards the end of episode 100.
We had Romeo join us just a moment ago. Oh, hold on, don't peek, don't peek.
Of course Wes joined us a minute ago and now Nick, right?
That's right.
Nick is sitting down to join us. Nick, welcome to Linux Unplugged.
Thank you for having me.
Now Nick, how was the drive up, first of all? I should start with that. Where did you come from?
I'm actually coming from Bremerton, so it was a little bit of a drive.
Yeah, I know, it feels like it's pretty far north when you're actually making the trip, huh?
When you look at it, first of all, that's not that bad.
But yeah, then you have to make the trip out there.
So Nick, I remember we were talking before we started, you just started kind of looking and moving into the technology field.
And so your day job isn't necessarily working with technology, so why the hell are you using Linux?
Well, I've always kind of been interested. Ever since high school, I've been playing with Ubuntu really.
And then I kind of got into a little deeper into it.
Just stuck with it?
Yeah, just kind of stuck with it actually. About six months ago, I completely got rid of Windows.
So how is it going to school, taking technology courses, do they accommodate the fact that you're a Linux user?
Or when they give you courseware and instructions, do they just assume you're on a Mac or you're on Windows?
Yeah, pretty much just have to figure everything out myself.
It's almost all Windows and a little bit of Mac here and there.
Do you end up having to run a VM? Is there just no way around it sometimes?
There was one class I had to run a VM for, just for Microsoft Office.
I had to do some stuff with a newer version of PowerPoint, but that was it.
And now maybe Office Online would help a little bit, I suppose.
The reason why I was kind of thinking about this is I was looking at this, we haven't talked about it yet.
Well, we kind of talked about it when it first came out.
But there's this Ubuntu-powered Intel Compute Stick. For $110, it's an x86 computer.
It's going to ship with a 64-bit version of Ubuntu 14.04 LTS, 1.3 GHz quad-core x86, 1 GB of RAM and 8 GB of storage.
And it just plugs into the HDMI port. $110 for this.
And this is going to run any x86-compatible application.
For schools and libraries and low-budget computers that can do basic computing, this seems like such a no-brainer.
Because you could get a $100 flat-screen computer monitor, plug this into the HDMI port, and you've got a full computer setup for $250 or something.
Yeah, that would be perfect for that whole situation.
I'm actually really surprised that more schools and stuff aren't using open-source software in Linux.
Well, what am I missing about these Compute Sticks? Because I think there's some skepticism in the Mumble Room about them, right?
Well, one thing is they're very easily stealable if they're just shoved in the back of a monitor.
Yeah, I guess so. But boy, laptops and tablets are also pretty easily stealable, but they still have them in schools and whatnot.
The Ubuntu ones also only have, I believe it was either a single gig or two gigs of RAM, where the Windows one has double that.
Ah, Wimpy, is that what you mean by it being a little more gimped?
Yeah, so way back when, Popey was reading a more optimistic brand of news than me and was saying that the Windows and Ubuntu versions were going to be the same.
But sadly, we find ourselves in the usual position where the Ubuntu version, yes, it's a bit cheaper, which is great,
but it's got one gig of RAM and eight gig of storage versus the two gig of RAM and 32 gigs of storage on the Windows version.
So that's disappointing, but I guess this is Microsoft's deep pockets subsidizing the hardware.
Is it that? Or is it Intel wanted to ship it for a cheaper price, but Microsoft couldn't agree on that because of the amount of RAM that Windows takes?
Well, in the netbook era, Microsoft did their damnedest, didn't they, to make sure that these devices shipped in such a fashion that they weren't ideal.
And they're bending over backwards for the Raspberry Pi B, or Raspberry Pi 2, whatever it is.
Yeah, I don't know that they're bending over backwards. I think that's lip service they're paying to the Raspberry Pi 2.
If you've actually looked at what's involved in getting Windows 10 running on a Raspberry Pi 2, it's, well, yeah.
It's a joke. And also it's command line only too, right?
Well, it's not so much that. It's the, you know, you must have Windows 10 preview installed in order to flash the device.
So you must have a Microsoft Connect account. You must have a Microsoft online account.
And there's also, and you must fill out every survey on the Microsoft Connect site before you get access to the Raspberry Pi 2 preview image download.
So there's a lot of stuff you have to do, and a lot of information you have to give away to get access to this.
So I do think those sticks are useful for the low end stuff, like to even, yeah, okay, it ships with Ubuntu,
but I can see a lot of people wanting to wipe that off and put something like a media center stuff,
and use a Bluetooth remote, or even an infrared remote or something, or a Bluetooth keyboard, and use it as a media playback device.
It's like a Chromecast, but completely open.
So, you know, the things that annoy me about Chromecast is I can't easily play local media without hacking the thing.
I can't tell it to use DNS servers other than Google, so if I wanted to bypass region locks and stuff, that's hard.
Whereas with this device, okay, it's a bit bigger, it takes a bit more power, and it's a little bit uglier than a Chromecast,
and it's a do-it-yourself thing, but I would expect very soon there will be people making x86 images for that kind of device.
Yeah, and wasn't Firefox working on a casting stick? Yeah.
Maybe instead of building the hardware they could just release the software and people could flash themselves,
but Wimby, you warned us maybe we are not going to want to replace the Ubuntu OS on the stick, what do you mean?
Not just yet. So the wireless device in these Intel compute sticks isn't supported in the mainline kernel just yet.
So if you're comfortable with patching your own kernel with the current out-of-tree drivers, then that's fine.
So, you know, this comes with all the hard work having been done for you, but if you want to run Kodi on it or Arch or something else,
then for the time being at least you're going to need to roll your own kernel to support it.
So maybe in a couple of months that won't be an issue, but just, you know, be fair warned that changing distros is not going to be trivial at the moment.
But this is way easier than using an ARM device like the mythical Mozilla thing that still hasn't arrived and we get no updates.
Right, BNX86, you mean kind of, yeah, the matchstick, that's what it was, the matchstick, thank you Jerem, thank you.
Yeah, yeah, I backed that, I'm still waiting as well. I think I did too.
Yes, I did back it.
And whilst I agree with Popey...
That is not from Mozilla themselves, just a heads up.
Yeah, no, it's not, it's a project built on top of their platform.
Thank you for the clarification.
But whilst I agree with Popey that, you know, x86 devices are far more flexible, versatile, just be fair warned that if you get one of these,
just be patient before you start wanting to experiment with other distributions.
Now we might have, maybe we'll see something better from Lenovo, right there, Warhead?
We might be seeing something from them that might be easier for us to use.
Yeah, they're basically redoing the same thing, branding it their way.
However, with my connections there, we might be able to get Linux running on it fast.
Nice, that would be cool, that would be good.
Theirs is going to run for $130, it says.
2.4 gigahertz Wi-Fi, HDMI compatible, I'm not seeing anything on the, where's the, probably just the same specs, huh?
It's probably right down to the letter, and then it's got the Lenovo branding and the WES inside it, so.
Yeah, it's got the Atom processor, it's got 32 gigabytes of storage, so it has a little bit more storage.
This one will be shipping with Windows 8, oh boy, what a winner that is going to be.
Who would want that?
I've seen some online that are built around the Core M, like in the MacBook.
And I can't remember the price point for those, but I've seen them out there.
Wimpy, before we wrap up, you have a little bit of news to share with us.
You are wheeling and dealing these days, my friend.
Not to stand still, you have another hardware partnership to talk about, tell me about it.
We do, so we have our second hardware partnership with an organization called LibreTrend, who are based in Portugal.
And they make the LibreBox, which is really about supporting free software.
So it supports Linux without any drivers that require blobs or anything like that.
So it's quite an interesting initiative because the guy behind it has handpicked all of the components,
has designed his own motherboard, has found a fabricator in China that actually makes his motherboard for him.
But then he actually manufactures the devices in Portugal, including the alloy casing is all bespoke build.
So this isn't an ODM device that he's putting a badge on, the whole thing is entirely bespoke and hand designed.
So if you're a BSD user, this is also a good choice because all of the hardware works.
And one of his aspirations was to actually get this all working with a core boot.
But that turns out it's quite a long and expensive process to remove a proprietary BIOS.
So at the moment, the LibreBox is using a traditional BIOS, although it doesn't have UEFI.
And in time, he's working on actually replacing that with core boot.
So the last vestiges in his mind of the freedom hating can be removed.
And he has a couple of revisions of this device in the works as well.
So in the not too distant future, there'll be another device announced.
And he's also working on something for 2016, which I can't say anything about, but I'm super excited about.
Sounds like it's going to be a fruitful partnership down the road, long term.
Well, I hope so. I mean, it's nice that these organizations have approached us and said,
we'd like to ship your operating system. That's really satisfying.
And it's great for me because this particular device, although they're based in Portugal, they ship worldwide.
So anyone can order these. And up until September the 13th, there's free global shipping as well.
So if you order one now, there won't be any costs.
And there was some criticism when the device was first released about the cost.
So he's listened to that. He watched what was going on on Reddit until our Linux went private.
And he's actually reduced the price of the device within a few days, having watched people's feedback.
So they're good eggs and they're doing the right stuff.
That's awesome.
And yeah, I'm looking forward to getting one of these.
I'm going to use one of these as a little codey box in the front room.
Perfect. You know, I think that's probably a perfect ending point right there because that's also been one of my favorite things
over the 100 episodes is watching you guys work on that project.
Watch Ubuntu Mate just sort of really, I don't know how else to describe it, blow up, blossom, explode,
and do like from going from something you guys started to really a well-known full flavor of Ubuntu now
with a couple of hardware partnerships and contributing to open source projects on a routine basis.
I mean, it's a pretty impressive journey. I don't even remember where and about the show's history we started talking about it.
But it's been going on for a while now and that's sprinkled throughout the history of the show too now.
So thank you, Wimpy, for chatting and sharing with us as you've gone along on that. That's really cool.
Oh, well, you're welcome. It's all Popeys fault. We can blame Popey.
Blame Popey.
And it started a year ago to give a take a few days.
Wow. Heck of a year.
That's when I went around to Popey's house and he got me started on this crazy idea.
All right. So that's been a heck of a year then. That went fast. Wow.
Yeah, it really did. Yeah. And it's kind of surprising because, you know, I made this for my mom, really.
My mom and my dad and my wife and my father-in-law.
And now I've got hundreds of friends and acquaintances I've made online that are using it. So it's quite satisfying.
So if people want to find out more about that hardware, go to ubuntu-mate.org and I will link it in the show notes as well
because that is a pretty, pretty cool deal. Congratulations.
So that's two now. That's two now, right? Two different hardware partnerships. Probably more coming I bet.
Yeah. Yeah. And the original partners, Entroware.
Yeah. Still around.
Their Apollo. Their Apollo device is the same as the Librem 13.
Right. So I've got one of those.
How do you like it?
Yeah, it's great. Although I'm working on kernel drivers for the trackpad at the moment because that's not properly supported.
I think that'll be a good post-show topic. Stay right there and let's talk about that.
All right. Thank you everybody for tuning in. If you've been here for 100 episodes, thank you for listening to all 100 episodes.
Join us next week. We'll be here. Go to jupyterblogcasting.com slash calendar to get our time.
Go to linuxactionshow.reddit.com to leave feedback and we'll see you right back here next week.
The show, the show. Thanks you guys. That was a lot of fun. Thank you. Thank you Nick.
You're welcome.
So Wimpy, tell me how is this Librem laptop?
Yeah, in the main it's very nice. So Entraware have been selling the Apollo for about three months now and part of the agreement I've got with them, they sent me some hardware.
So they've sent me two of the laptops to evaluate and the Apollo, which is the Librem 13 I've now learned, that's for me to keep.
And that's now my daily machine that I use. So it's a full metal aluminium case.
My traditional machines are rather clunky and old, you know, thinkpads with traditional quality thinkpad keyboards, which I never thought I would be able to give up.
And the Apollo's got a chiclet keyboard, which I thought I was going to hate. And I've actually realized that actually that's a really good keyboard. I really like the keyboard.
I'm very happy with that.
I think Noah's going to get one.
I'm telling you now, everything that I'm telling you could directly translate to the Librem 13 because in my contact with Entraware and then consequently the ODM and some of the component manufacturers, I've learned that what I have is the Librem 13.
It's the same device. The one difference being is that Entraware shipped theirs with a traditional BIOS, whereas Librem are hoping to use Coreboot.
But in terms of the specs and the case and all of the other features, it's the same.
But the issue is this, it's got a really nice large trackpad, but the kernel currently detects that as a PS2 mouse, so consequently there's no gesture recognition.
And what I've also learned, and brace yourself because you've backed the Librem 15, haven't you?
The Librem 15 has the same trackpad in it made by BYD. So I've contacted the component manufacturer BYD to try and get the specs and I got a general PDF that isn't all that much help.
There's a couple of people I've found on various mailing lists that have had a go at reverse engineering the packet protocol for the USB device to try and enable the full gesture support, and that's quite hard going.
I've made some progress but I don't know enough about kernel development and in particular the input stack, so I'm kind of struggling with that.
So what this means is if you actually look at the product updates for the Librem 15, in one of those they actually acknowledge that the trackpad only works as a PS2 device, which means you've got basic trackpad movement, move your finger around and the cursor follows you and you've got edge scrolling, that works.
But there's no two finger scrolling or gestures, which means that when you need to right click and drag something that's a bit awkward.
So maybe somebody needs to hold the candle to Purism's toes and just find out what their plan is regarding the trackpad support is.
Actually I had a similar mouse on my Asus laptop and when I installed the new version of Fedora 22 it actually worked right out of the box, so whatever they're doing.
Yeah they have a new lib input library, doesn't Fedora 22 have a new one?
It does, yeah. In fact I think Fedora are actually going to make that mandatory in the next release, so if projects aren't using lib input they're going to struggle because their libraries are going away.